hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast advancing Parkinson's
disease cell therapy transplanting
cryopreserved IPSC derived two neurons
that will be presented by dr. Dustin
Whitman we're excited to bring to you
this educational webinar presented by
lab roots and sponsored by cellular
dynamics international cellular dynamics
international is a fujifilm company is a
fujifilm company and is the world's
largest producer of human iPS cells and
human iPS cells derived cell types
they're growing product offering
includes the iso products which are
cells that are differentiated from
healthy donors such as the iso maryland
i sell cardiomyocytes etc and the
lifestyle products that provide
reprogramming genetic engineering and
differentiation services from your
choice of patient samples these cells
are currently being used in drug
discovery toxicity testing stem cell
banking and cell therapy third cell
therapy development to learn more about
cellular dynamics please visit www com I
am Susan devorah and I'm from cellular
dynamics and I'll be the moderator for
the event today before we begin I just
like to remind everyone that this is an
interactive event and so therefore I
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time throughout the presentation
just click on the green Q&A button
that's located in the lower corner of
the presentation window and type your
question in the box that appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we can at the end of the presentation
also the presentation will be viewed in
the slide window and you can enlarge
that window just by clicking on the
screen icon that is located on the lower
right
Corner finally if you have any problems
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you are having a problem at this
time I'd like to introduce dr. Dustin
Wakeman dr. Wakeman is an assistant
professor at rush university medical
center where his research goals are
directed at determining the long-term
value of stem cell-based therapeutics in
neurodevelopmental and neurodegenerative
diseases dr. Wakemans research is
primarily focused on preclinical testing
of dopamine neurons for dopamine
replacement therapy using a rational
course of animal models to predict
translational clinical outcomes his lab
is also utilizing pluripotent stem cells
to develop new strategies for modeling
disorders of the central nervous system
their goal is to use patient-derived
ipscs as an in vitro platform to model
disease specific phenotypes and develop
new druggable targets as well as using
an in vivo studies to mimic human
disease human disease in the rodent and
non-human primate brains dr. Wakeman
received his BS in biology from the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign and then completed his
PhD in biomedical sciences at the
University of California at San Diego
please join me in welcoming dr. Wakeman
I'll melt turn the presentation over to
him well thank you sue for that very
kind introduction and thank you cellular
dynamics international lab roots for
sponsoring this talk and as soon mention
I'm going to be talking to you today
about our work utilizing pluripotent
stem cells as a potential therapy for
Parkinson's disease so a quick
disclosure i'ma consultants and
recipient of research funding from CDI
which is work i will show you today so
there are three main learning objectives
day first is to distinguish between the
different types of cell-based
therapeutics for
instance disease second will be to
actually define what an authentic
McMurray lineage dopamine on actually is
and then third will be able to identify
key components for a successful very
potent stem cell-based clinical trial
compartments instances but first what is
Parkinson's disease well Parkinson's
disease is anatomically characterized by
a specific degeneration of dopaminergic
neurons between the substantia [ __ ]
that is deep in the midbrain of your
brain and you can see in the bottom
right here in a Parkinson's disease
patients who literally have a loss of
these black substance neurons and these
neurons actually projects fibers or
exons into the stratum of the caudate
and putamen which is where the
dopaminergic transmission actually takes
place so when we have degeneration of
these neurons we get a characteristic
clinical symptoms of Parkinson's disease
seems like tremor rigidity postural
instability that you've all heard of and
again this is a stem cell talk so I just
want to sort of characterize the
different types of cells I'm going to be
talking about today now it's sort of a
hierarchy of the stem cell we have the
embryonic stem cells and IPS cells and
useful in stem cell so these cells are
pluripotent and what that means is that
they can give rise to any cell type in
the body so we're talking about heart
cells skin cells and in our case today
we'll be talking about neurons dopamine
neurons now if we take those cells and
we sort of coax them in the neural
lineage we get what we call the neural
stem cell that cell is multi coat and
when we mean by that is you can at least
in the case of the cns a central nervous
system it can make a sir size of the
commander sites and neurons now these
cell types have a unique characteristic
and that they can software new so we can
make a large number of these cells from
a small population now we take those
cells and we further differentiate them
we get installed a lineage restricted
neuroblast and then we can actually move
that sail towards a dopaminergic neuron
or fully differentiated postmitotic
around so these cell types are as i
mentioned postmitotic so the number you
started with is the number you have at
the end so really the beauty of stem
cells was from a regenerative medicine
standpoint is that they have the
capacity to both self-renew so we can
make a whole bunch of them from the
small population we can actually
differentiate them into very specific
cell types that we'd like to use for
third now this concept of using neural
cells for transplantation and
Parkinson's disease is by no means a new
field so it's been going on for over 30
years and the first cell type that
really gained traction even made it into
clinical trials and showed some clinical
efficacy and open-label trials was the
cell we called a fetal venture music
cephalon so the fetal vm is the area of
midbrain and the fetus where those
dopamine neurons are born and will
eventually degenerate during the
Parkinson's disease degenerative process
now as I mentioned there were some
positive outcomes of these trials
however the main issue here is that it
takes about 1 to 8 feet assisted
treatment an individual patient so it's
extremely hard to source that type of
tissue and the tissue itself is somewhat
heterogeneous so remembering arts are
sort of our hierarchy other lineages we
just talked about the next obvious step
I say well maybe we can use the
dopaminergic neuron blast and that also
has shown some success in animal models
however again we still have we're sort
of plagued with this problem where we're
still using one fetus to treat an
individual patient so that doesn't get
rid of the sourcing issue or the
heterogeneity so if we take a step even
further back I'll be showing you some
work today previous work online and
colleagues or reused fetal human neural
stem cells in this case they were
derived from the stuff in particular
zone and that has the added advantage of
you can take one fetus create a neural
stem cell line and you can treat a large
number of patients and then of course we
have the majority to stop be talking
about our pluripotent stem cells or ES
cells and our IPS cells where we can
make both neural stem cells as well as a
full-on postmitotic clearing of dopamine
neurons and so really the advantage of
these pluripotent stem cells is that
their renewable right so we can make as
many of them as we need and relatively
make pretty much relatively unlimited
supply and secondarily that we can
actually make very specific cell types
and again for the purpose of today's
talk will be talking about midbrain
dopamine neurons so back in 2007 we
published a paper when I was in heaven
Snyder's group where we showed that
after transplantation of these neural
stem cells these are human fetal neural
stem cells into the parkinsonian primate
brain we could actually alleviate
April dysfunction and so we were quite
happy to find this when did the
histology what we found were we had
these beautiful brdu positive th
positive cells so these were donor cells
that real able to be our to you and they
were th positive and what that means is
that th is a tyrosine hydroxylase is the
rate-limiting enzyme and dopamine
synthesis so really forgot to talk to me
when I talk about th I'm primarily
talking about dopamine rounds so we're
quite happy to find these th positive
cells and fortunately when we counted
them there were only about three to five
percent of the transplanted cells that
actually differentiate and we started to
ask ourselves is that really enough
cells to accommodate this type of
functional improvement Lisa we thought
well maybe something else is going on
here I notice subsequent papers would
actually show that that was probably the
case or about ninety-five percent of
meself remained as undifferentiated
neural stem cells and it looked like
they were really acting through
secondary mechanisms to restore and
rescue the endogenous dopamine neurons
that have been spared so at the same
time when I was an avid Snyder group
human embryonic stem cells were really
becoming in bogan we had some really
good techniques to actually make neural
cells and not just neural cells we were
learning how to make dopamine cells and
so basically what I want you to
understand here is that whenever we're
working with stem cells really what
we're trying to do is model human
development okay so when I'm trying to
make a Cuban dopamine neuron from an
embryonic stem cell or an IPS cell all
I'm trying to do is do my best to
recapitulate the normal developmental
cues that are involved in hearing the
embryo and fetus to actually make these
cells and so you can see here we had a
variety of different mortgage ins and
other chemical factors and we can
actually derive these best and positive
sacks one positive neural stem cells you
see this nice little call rosette
structures and so we were able to make
these neuroepithelial precursors you can
then add a variety of other
differentiation and maturation factors
in this case things like wint proteins
sonic hedgehog and a variety of other
factors we can actually differentiate
these cells into primarily and here we
have 95% beta3 tubular and positive
neurons caesars a neuronal marker and
then of these cells about seventeen
percent actually became dopaminergic in
their face this was really on par with
what other groups were showing and
show improvement in rodent models so we
thought okay well what happens to these
cells if we transplant them into our
parkinsonian monkey and so we did a sort
of a proof-of-concept experiment where I
labeled these cells with gfp and we
transplanted them into both Easter item
as well as into the substantial magram
you can see on these two rep panels here
we had very nice grass revival in the
top right panel these are again betas
reticulum positive you can see here in
the bottom right panel they had a very
nice large sort of this inner onal a
large soma as well as a very extensive
fiber innovation so this was great
because we were showing that I only
could use human embryonic stem cell
drive so i'll survive edge they were
also projecting pretty extensive fibers
when reading the host / n c'mon this is
only 28 days post-transplantation now
unfortunately when I stained for
tyrosine hydroxylase I found zero cells
that were th positive so remember
seventeen percent of these cells when n
th positive so it really started to ask
myself what's going on here and sort of
where did we go wrong now I mentioned
previously and I want to reiterate a
stem cell biologists all we're really
trying to do is understand and
recapitulate what's going on during
normal development so really the best
chem cell biologists are really good
developmental biologists so this is just
a schematic here of the rodent brain a
very early during development and really
what I want to focus on here is this
midline area where the forebrain and
hindbrain meet there's a gradient of
sonic hedgehog and a variety of other
factors but if you take a cross-section
here at the midbrain and what I want you
to focus on is on that right panel there
is that little red area that's an area
called the foreplay and it turns out
that's where these dopaminergic neurons
are actually born and in a series of
brilliant experiments and very carefully
thought out experiments Ranma Chi who is
a fantastic developmental biologist
specifically in our field for making
dopamine neurons sort of figured out
that there's this master regulator Fox a
to this transcription factor that really
does sort of regulate these early
dopaminergic progenitor so you can see
down in the bottom three panels at
embryonic date night and a half we have
a very early expression of the sonic
hedgehog and sell an X 1 B transcription
factor and then you see a 12.5 this is
the beginning of those th positive
dopamine neurons so again through a
series of elegant experiments he really
showed that by knocking this gene outfox
a 2 he could actually induce a parking
something like symptom and so what I
want you to sort of remember for the
rest of this talk at these two genes
he's Fox a2l mx1 be in that these genes
really do specify what we call an
authentic midbrain lineage for plate
dopaminergic neuron ok so now Ranma Chi
has some extremely talented postdocs
that have come through his lab and one
of those particular post Doc's that came
to his lab and now is the phenomenal
stem cell scientist and developmental
biologist was Lorenz stir in 2011 he
published his paper in Nature I was
assigned to Chris being the first author
and I this is uh both myself and dr.
Jeffrey Cordova a rush were actually
quite fortunate to be able to work with
dr. scooter on this project and one of
the rest basically showed in this paper
was that this technique we were using
this rosette based strategy was
completely wrong and in fact we were
doing was neural izing cells towards it
actually an anterior directed her fate
and while the ren showed was and again a
specifics here these chemicals aren't
really all that important right now but
I want to want to point out as one
specific molecule that's his green box
on the bottom the chir molecule you're
singing that's basically a win a win
activator and so will arrange shown this
paper was that when you activate
canonical win signaling you could
actually induce floorplate neurogenesis
and this turned out to be a huge
breakthrough and really a paradigm shift
for the field so i'm going to show you
that data now so the focus now again the
top left panel here there's a floor
plate derive dopaminergic neurons that
technique i just showed you and what we
have here is LMX won a fox a to
expression in these cells and you can
see the old technique the rosette based
technique right below you only get the
th positive cells not the LMX one day in
fox a to expression remember those are
those two critical transcription factors
that are important in the floor plate
where the mid where the midbrain
dopamine neurons are actually formed and
to the right of that we have th and your
one there want another one of these
pro-government ergic genes
and you can see both techniques give you
your one positive th positive cells so
well it looked like we were making true
dopamine neurons with our old strategy
in fact we weren't actually we didn't
have a whole story wouldn't have all the
signaling process and that's just really
quantified over and be in the top right
and I don't think we're remaking the
right types of cells with this strategy
this foreplay strategy but we weren't
making the wrong types of cells and by
that I mean these serotonergic neurons
and gabaergic neurons that have actually
been implicated in some of the problems
with fetal graphs so we have expression
of these transcription factors and the
wrens very quickly realized he was onto
something and so they transplanted these
cells into several models of Parkinson's
disease early models of Parkinson's
disease I'm going to talk about one here
just to show you the data this is the
six hydroxy dopamine lesion adult brat
and you can see these crafts he's
beautiful human NK am positive th
positive fox a to positive graphs
indicating again that these are
maintained and midbrain lineage and
importantly they then went on to show
through three different independent
tests that when they transplanted these
cells compared to sham controls the
animals actually had restoration of
normal behaviour you're seeing in the
bottom left panel k a complete complete
restoration from the in federal interest
rotations we have stepping test almost
completely towards baseline again and
then the cylinder test which is a Borla
make anisha test and both these stepping
tests and cylinder tests which are
pharmacologically independent and more
stringent we have a complete reversal
here in behavior significantly so really
what we're showing here is that not only
did Lorenzo's group find out that they
can make these cells that they were
actually functioning this is one of
these a functioning long-term this is
one of the problems with some of the
other techniques is that they really
didn't have this long-term effect so
this is about the time when dr. Stuart
contacted dr. Kurt over and I and asked
us if we would be interested in
collaborating on using these cells in
parkinsonian primate models as proof
concept and so of course we we were very
happy to collaborate and that turned out
to be a really good decision and sort of
shaped our program from there on out
so this is three months
post-transplantation into the mptp usual
parkinsonian monkey in this ground
standing on the left is human side of
lesson so anywhere you see brown
staining here is a grafted cell and you
can see and b is that you taemin's is
the target area the cells you see the
innervation into the containment as well
as extensive fiber alcove into Layden's
white matter tracks in the corona
radiata now before we were not in the
studies I had done previously I was not
able to find th positive cells so it's
quite happy when I staying for tyrosine
hydroxylase and we found a large number
these th positive dopaminergic neurons
within the P terminal graphed here I was
the same record CNA and then of course
just as importantly we had maintenance
of Fox a2 expression within these cells
indicating again they were maintained
his midbrain lineage now I wasn't every
single cell that was foxy to positive
but the overwhelming majority of them
work in a sense of efforts are underway
in doctors tutors lab to actually purify
this population into an even greater
extent so what exactly do these cells
look like morphologically well what I
want to point out I hope you can
appreciate that it's not just one or two
cells that are mature or survive we have
large groups of these cells you can see
panel see they have sort of a network of
these cells and they highly innervate
the host for income as you can see in
these very long axons and when you look
in detail at these cells at high
magnification you can see in handel's d
and e on the right that we actually have
this very mature morphology and what we
call this sort of angular Samata which
is characteristic of midbrain dopamine
yawns and again you can see a nice fiber
outgrowth funding cells now I mentioned
before that all we're really trying to
do is make this fetal p.m. cell in a
homogeneous matter and in large numbers
right that was the whole issue of these
cells were very hard to source so how
did these cells matchup this is actual
an actual patient that was in a clinical
trial that received fetal venture
amazing cephalic cells you can seeing a
is very nice Network highly innervated
cells and B and C that nice angular
morphology within the stoma of these
cells and compared to ourselves actually
see very similar morphology of the cells
and we also see the sort of network
information again ourselves are only at
three
suppose transplantation so we we saw
this data we thought we're quite
happened he thought would really on the
right track so the next step and network
sort of finishing up right now is a
long-term functional study and Viva this
is a one year study using non-human
primate parkinsonian animals and we're
really starting now and dr. suitors
group through my stem funding has really
worked on sort of creating this final
product a GMP compatible product from
human embryonic stem cells so we're
really excited about this product now
one issue that we need to think about
when advancing pluripotent stem cell
therapy with parkinson's disease is
immune system regulation so the idea
here is that we have an allograft you're
going to either eat a new expression at
least short term to some extent or ii
have to do something called HLA matching
where you actually match the MHC alleles
very similar to something what you would
see in a whole organ transplant I'll
talk about that a little bit more than
minute that HLA matching would be much
more difficult using human embryonic
stem cells so this is really when I
became sort of interested and almost
like ice fixated on using induced
pluripotent stem cells so as you know
IPS cells are derived from individuals
and of course we can then create
different types of cells i won the nobel
prize in 2012 relatively recently
considering their inception and so now i
want to focus the rest of my talk on the
work I've been doing with cellular
dynamics international now CDI is a
rather innovative company because really
what they do is is they're really good
at making not only IPS cells from
disease disease patients as well as
healthy patients but they're also really
good at making derivative cell so hard
cells lung cells and in this case brain
cells and for us postmitotic around so
not only are they good at making the
cells they're really good at crowd
preserving themselves and so that's
important because when we think about
going to the FDA for a clinical trial
for something like transplantation and
regenerative medicine the FDA requires
you to have a very high level of QA QC
on your cell
and so it's important that you can make
these cells with high efficiency and
very large batches and be able to do all
the QA QC and still have enough cells
left over and test-retest reliability to
actually create therapeutic for a larger
set of patients so you've all seen some
sort of version of the slide this is my
simplified version of the slide and
basically we have is we have patient a
in blue at the top and CDI basically
collects a blood sample they use
episomal reprogramming or we call this
footprint free reprogramming to generate
induced pluripotent stem cells and then
of course we can take and do support
button stem cells and we can
differentiate them into the cell type of
our choice and for us today we'll be
talking about midbrain dopamine neurons
so this is actually the product they
called I self doba you can buy this off
the shelf of them right now any day of
the week so I'm going to tell you about
some of our our work using these cells
sort of the right arm of this of this
strategy this first sight or therapeutic
I'm not going to talk today about using
these cells as a research tool however I
will say they are very nice for use for
in vitro diagnostics as well so there's
really two pathways we can look at when
you think about cellular therapies for
regenerative medicine using IPS cells
one is the sort of the ideal situation
the autologous transplant that is taking
a self from that patient driving the IPS
cell on making our differentiated cell
type of choice and transplanting that
back into the patient of course the
advantage here is at least theoretically
you should not need a new suppression
because you have a complete mash of
alleles on the amex elem and logan plus
i now the other idea here is alginate
transplant that's something we call the
hafla mention approach and that is
basically use the exact same procedure
like youjizz and process for a whole
organ transplantation being that you
sort of try and match as many of those
MHC alleles as possible to get as close
of a match and so thinking about this
you could take cells from healthy
patients we genotyped them previously
you know exactly what the combination of
wheels are and then you basically pull
out the real combination that matches
your patient the best okay and so we're
interested in both of these aspects and
we're pursuing both of them at the same
time and I think you'll see that in the
talk how to sort of go hand in hand
so I mention these cells these ISIL
dopant ions well what exactly are these
ISIL talking about so this is gene
expression analysis looking as his
rt-pcr looking at these cells at
different time points post post thaw
between seven and 42 days and that's
comparing it in the red bar here deemed
to the human substantia [ __ ] and I'm
not going to go through all these genes
but just a few i'll point out Fox a 20
MX 1 or 1 th again to those jeans I've
been talking about another important
they'd bring their Genesis genes and
what I want you to appreciate is that
sort of a cross is gene span if they're
very similar to what we find in the
human substantial item it's really what
this says is that these IPS derived for
dopamine neurons really are expressing
these four plate and midbrain specific
genes so the gene expression looks good
uh what about protein expression well
one of these cells look like in vitro so
the top left here you see bright field
image of these cells is the 70s
post-transplantation which is nice large
soma and they send these axons out all
throughout the dish and these will
continue to grow and I said we were very
nice and neutral losers diagnostic as
well and of course you can see here
there greater than ninety percent Fox a
20 mx1 th positive and again they
express th and we used to a quick facts
analysis in these cells from Fox a tu
and th you see the greater than seventy
five percent of the cells are actually
called positive and that number is
actually increased even more ways to
sort of CDI as we find this process now
one of the most important pieces of data
I've actually going to show you today is
in the bottom right corner that's the
thought viability of these cells so you
might not think that that's really all
that important of PC data but when you
think about trying to create this this
cell product and go into the clinic this
turns out to be a big deal so before I
worked these cells I'd never seen any
postmitotic dopamine neuron that you
could actually freeze and thaw back with
with high efficiency and so what you're
seeing here is around seventy-five
percent follow that viability in our
hands were usually getting around eighty
to eighty-five percent it really depends
on the user but suffice it to say is you
get a large number of surviving cells
out of his file of cells and so that
really become
imported later on when we think about
trying to apply this to a patient
population and I'll touch on that in a
few minutes so again we have a nice gene
expression profile and of course these
nice pretty pictures these cytochemistry
pictures but when I think about protein
expression I'm usually sold by western
blots so this is just a few of the
proteins that we passing through western
blossom but you can see that the DA here
represents the i sold open neurons gaba
here is a highly gabaergic population
this is actually another IPS line that I
ps2 regner online that CBI cells that I
sell neurons which are almost eighty
percent gabaergic and then we have these
NSCs but fetal neural stem cells these
are actually clubs Benson's cortical
neural stem cells that we grown
dopaminergic media and what I want you
to appreciate here is that only these
dopaminergic population or foxy to th
positive you see some of these other
genes I've talked about be met to ger to
being other midbrain markers as well as
having synaptic proteins so all in all
we seem to have the right gene
expression protein gene expression
profile as well as proteins being
expressed in these cells so that being
said the next question really is are
these cells actually making dopamine
okay and so this is an Eliza that was
performed on these I sold open neurons
and as a controller these are ice on
neurons that's that gabaergic population
I was just talking about and you can see
in blue if this is just the amount of
dopamine that's being secreted into the
basal media using this case hbss and
then we can also apply casting chloride
stimulation and actually get an increase
in secretion of dopamine into the media
again suggesting that these cells are
indeed making dopamine secreting it and
we're actually the process of validating
this with hplc and looking at the
metabolites of dopamine go Chum vanilla
casa de endo pack so when I say
functionality of course most people are
going to faint electrical activity and
that of course means doing
electrophysiology so we patch clamped on
to these cells and you can see an a we
have these cells they're firing
spontaneous action potentials and then
be when we apply occurrence they
actually also will fire action
potentials
and fire evoke occurrence so it looks
like these cells are functionally active
and we take that a step further and
we've actually shown that not only are
they functionally active but they
actually had very characteristic
inhibitor responses to both TTX for
sodium channels as well as te a for
potassium channels so really looks like
we have functional ion channels and
there's been a quite a bit more
electrophysiology and MEA data that's
been generated by a calm Mangum at CBI
as well as in gym surmise group by Zhang
Zi that we are continuing to pursue
really showing in D that they have the
right receptors and like they actually I
responding in a very similar way to a
good brain dopamine though so I don't
have time to show you all that data
today suffice it to say that at this
point we're quite convinced that we had
the real deal the right type of
dopaminergic neuron had very high
viability post law and so the next step
of course of our group specializes in is
testing these cells in animal models of
lumin disorders in this case the 600
dopamine asian rat and the mptp vision
primate and now all this work I'm going
to show you for the rest of this talk he
really been spearheaded by these two
gentlemen graduate student David Marmion
and a very talented technician mentions
Benjamin Hiller in our lab who have
really taken on this this project full
board and of course our overall goal
here is to figure out what the Nassau
cells are safe and efficacious to go for
an IND approval from the FDA so now I
mentioned the sort of the ideal
situation is for a neurosurgeon to be
able to call down to the technician in
the lab and say I need X cc's of cells
and let's say 30 minutes and the
technician very easily take that bio
cells thought in this case we actually
centrifugal centrifugal wash those cells
twice to remove the DMSO of the crowd
preservative and then we are
transplanting those cells directly at
that point this whole process takes
roughly 26 to 27 minutes from the time
we take the that vile out of the liquid
nitrogen to the time it is actually
being injected into the brain
and so why is it so important because
these cells do not require any
subculture in this data I'm going to
show you and that's important because we
want to really minimize the amount of
human exposure and human error that can
be introduced into this scenario because
that remain that's really what keeps our
quality our QA QC and makes this much
more therapeutically viable to treat a
large number of patients over a large
number of different centers so it
doesn't require any really any special
any special technical work or any
special equipment so that being said
what we decided to do was a very simple
proof of concept at this point I was
very skeptical that this would work I'd
never seen anything like this before so
we basically transplanted these cells
into cyclosporine immunosuppressed
regular add to this is just two weeks
later these are these are intact healthy
rats what I think you can appreciate
here naav are these human egg-cam and
human cytoplasm brass said I only
surviving but they're already
innervating the host / Akuma at two
weeks post-transplantation you can see
there are also dopaminergic th positive
and importantly they're also fox8 to
positive as you can see here by
co-localization with human repro I
around these th possum cells so we were
quite happy to find if he sells not only
survived and then grafted but they also
maintain the midbrain managed so of
course the next step was to see whether
or not they were safe and the FDA of
course is primarily and most importantly
a safety organization they are very very
interested in making sure that you're
not going to make patients worse and
thankfully so so when we think about
stem cells the first thing we think
about your safety and regenerative
medicine is ourselves proliferating
right so last thing I want to do is make
a tumor a brain tumor inside of a
patient especially a Parkinson's patient
that's probably going to live for 10 or
15 years at least in which case even a
few proliferating cells could be a
problem and so on the left here you see
this is the graph zone here giving
nuclei and then in B we have our KSS e7
standing which stains proliferative
cells and as a internal control you see
in the bottom left panel be double Prime
that's just a sub ventricular zone and
ventricular area which is where the
endogenous neural stem cells are in the
rodent brain as he cause of control and
I've looked at over 50 animals at two
weeks post-transplantation
and I can tell you I have not found a
single ki-67 positive sell it was rather
hard to believe in fact I look so hard I
thought I finally found one here you see
him be primed at that inset panel where
the red arrow is I thought I finally
found one I said AHA there is one event
of course when I went looked at high
magnification turns out that was just a
piece of dust as an artifact from the
from the slide so not only are these
cells surviving maintaining the midbrain
lineage but it also looks like they have
an extremely safe profile and if they're
not proliferating so we were quite happy
with this and so the next step of course
was to go into a rodent model of
parkinson's disease and for us that the
six hydroxy don't mean me should rat and
so the model is quite simple you inject
neurotoxin 6-hydroxydopamine into the
medial forebrain bundle that is the
bundle of axons that runs from the
dopaminergic neurons in the substantia
[ __ ] into the striatum where they
release dopamine and when we reach in
these animals what we find is a
unilateral Lucien so the right side here
is the muse you know left side is intact
as you can see in the bottom right panel
be that all of these substantial nagra
would bring dopamine neurons are
completely wiped out and we have a
degeneration these neurons we also get
subsequent degeneration of their
terminals within the striatum so you can
see the lack of th staying in the
striatum as well and then from there is
quite simple we actually transplant the
cells into the lesion hemisphere and we
see whether or not we can actually
restore with dopaminergic deficit now
way we know we have a stable lesion is
we can actually use this test called the
amphetamine induce rotation testing so
basically what we have is rotationally
symmetry in these animals and they'll
actually once given a dose of
d-amphetamine they will rotate and if
you get really the cells of animals will
reduce their rotations and normalize and
sort of have a zero output and I'll show
you I'll show you more of that data
later on but really important part here
is that we're actually able to show that
we have a stable lesion and we're very
careful in our lab we do several tests
three tests over six to eight week
period and we were very stringent
criteria for inclusion into our
functional studies
so once we had our animals lesions and
we felt like we had the right cell type
we transplanted these cells again these
are csa meeting suppress
6-hydroxydopamine sprague-dawley rats we
let these cells go for six months and
which you can see in c and d is we had
very nice survival of both human and cam
and human nuclei positive grafton cells
and i hope you can see on the right
hemisphere where we actually projected
the cells is brown staining all
throughout that graph in that's
integrating the entire straight I'm
indicating that indeed we have human
fibers throughout this the injector
stratum you don't see that on the
contralateral non lesion non-drafted
site and you can see in human nuclei
that not only are these cells from our
human n can survive in an integrating
brain but the cell bodies themselves are
staying exactly where we transplanted
them into scrap so and that's important
because when we do biodistribution
studies and we're looking at safety we
really need to know where our cells are
at it's it's always helps when they're
not moving around going funny places so
we're we're actually pretty happy to
find that the cells really stay exactly
where they were and you can really
appreciate that they're using the human
nuclei standing there and panel can be
so the next question really was what
about dopaminergic dopaminergic cells
are they go from energic and so what we
have here on the bottom right again we
have our grafted cells this is targeting
Hydrox leasing and you can really see
now compared to what i showed you
earlier where we had no really note of
dopaminergic fibers we have complete
renovation of the injected hemisphere
and it's really important to point this
out the bottom left here is that six
months is that same animal the
substantia [ __ ] is still completely
lesion so it's not what we were rescuing
endogenous cells in this process and it
also confirms that we had a complete
stable region so I want to just I want
you really to appreciate what I'm
talking about what I'm talking about
innervation so this is that same animal
I was just showing you and I was that
control animal earlier that I was
showing you this is six months post
transplantation and all I've done is
I've taken these th images and I've
inverted them so you can really see
really brings out that stain so I hope
you can appreciate in the top left panel
ABG that we really do have complete
renovation of that straight and all that
blue and light stain that you see all
throughout the stratum and that's
compared now to the right side where we
have up to six hydroxy Joe communication
control we don't see any of that
innovation so this was fantastic we're
really excited about this but again our
job here really is not to have pretty
graphs to innervate our job is to see if
we can actually rescue functional
deficits in it and parkinsonian animals
and so I mentioned this M feta me
induced rotational test earlier and so
what I want to point out here is this
blue lines little minor animals that
were grafted with these cells that when
we actually did the histology on the
cells we found graphs some of them were
quite large some of them was smaller but
every single animal had complete
restoration of normal behavior normal
rotations deficits that we see and you
can see in black is the vehicle control
these are animals that were given media
sham I'm sorry media injection instead
of the cells and then the red line here
these are actually animals that received
a cell transplant and actually when we
did histology did not have any surviving
craft for whatever reason and so this is
important because you might guess that
if your grab did not survive you should
not get better that's exactly what we
saw so the blue line actually represents
an out of six rats the red line is not a
4x and that black line is antenna for
rats as well so we were you know again
we are really happy to see that our
histology matched our behavior right so
if the animal had a graft and again it
could be a small graft or large graph it
actually got better so this is just one
test one functional test we can do and
there's another test called the April
morphine-induced rotation and while
amphetamine-induced rotations really is
a surrogate for dopamine release April
working rotations really more of a
surrogate for innovation and has to do
with d1 d2 receptors suffice it to say
we see the exact same significant result
in the animals that have a successful
graft versus the lesion or non
successful graph where we have this
reversal of deficit to me think with
this trend here you can see it's turning
towards baseline we think as we continue
and we're looking into this in our
long-term studies now
so again mrs. these were really
fantastic results showing that we could
reverse motor deficits using these crap
reserve neurons and I just want to
stress again that these cells were just
thawed no sub culturing and were
transplanted with two very simple washes
right back into the these animals brains
this is six months posttransplantation
so of course we're interested in safety
as I mentioned before so again I looked
these graphs and we found 0 KS 67
positive cells means graphs again you
see the southern tricular zone as the
control and then of course we wanted to
measure the total number of surviving
cells and the number of th positive
cells so an i and j you can see really
the morphology of these cells are
extremely mature highly authorized and
innervated sending axons out into the
prank come up and when we counted these
cells of the total 450,000 that we
actually injected into these animals we
saw around twenty-four twenty-five
percent on average ranging upwards
towards 30 percent some animals and of
those cells presento surviving cells
about thirty five percent of them were
actually th positive and this is
actually in line and actually in line or
better than other reported groups with
hughes in human embryonic human
embryonic stem cells or ourselves and
those were non cloud for sure so again
these results are extremely promising
and so we were really happy and you know
obviously that we were able to restore
function so the next step then was
really to find out what would happen in
the disease environment so all this data
I've shown you so far are using cells
from a healthy individual so this sort
of would be that that application that
hello genetic application where we could
do a haplotype match what would happen
if we actually use cells from
Parkinson's disease patient right so
there might be huge differences between
driving cells from a disease patient and
how those cells actually go back in and
in Parkinson's disease what happens over
time is these cells in the brain the
dopaminergic neurons develop
we call alpha-synuclein inclusion so
we're really really interested right now
is figuring out whether or not or any
differences between the two approaches
and this will really inform us how we
want to go forward towards the FDA for
for a clinical trial so right now and
this is a work that I'm doing in
collaboration with dr. Deborah hall and
the rush movement disorders clinic we've
already started enrolling and actually
we're driving cells from very early
stage sporadic parkinson's disease
patients so this would sort of be our
target population that we would go for
and this is really a proof of concept
for the amount of time it would take for
us to actually go from the patient back
into having a functional cell and so
it's very straightforward again we're
driving using episomal reprogramming
driving IPS cells making the
dopaminergic neurons CD is and crowd
preserving them and then we're testing
them in animal models of Parkinson's
disease we've already began a derivation
process and differentiation process on
to donors and we now have two more
donors lined up representing both male
and female sexes as well as multiple
ethnicities so we're really interested
in looking again how do these cells
compare are there any cross sex or cross
ethnicity differences to really get try
and get sort of a more Universal idea
about how ourselves will function and
animal models right towards creating
this ind package so i just mentioned
sort of our ongoing experiment with
autologous cells we are taking these
cells all of these cells and can we are
going to compare them side-by-side in a
12-month functional in vivo study now
this is going to use a thymic new grass
we are going to have to worry about a
new suppressing the animals animals
really don't respond well to new
suppression for 12 months it can be
somewhat toxic and you can have other
off target side effects that we don't
want to confound our experiments again
we're really interested in this
autologous versus allogeneic approach so
looking at the hackle match approach how
do those healthy cells compared versus
are sporadic PD cells and and I
mentioned it's a functional studies so
when I say function I think about things
like electrophysiology what types of
action potentials are they flying how
are they firing use ash
attentions really getting in depth about
looking at that type of information
that's being done in collaboration with
dr. Jim Jeremiah or Northwestern
University here in Chicago and then
we're also very interested in really
looking at the type of synapses that
these cells are making work what type of
cells are cementing on what type of host
cells that send Matty nauman that I'm
really doing that through electron
microscopy as well as in the raid
tomography in collaboration with dr.
Gann Nicholson and his graduate student
in usual here at rush university so our
next step really was after we had our
functional study was to look at safety
and toxicity in vivo and in this case we
really wanted with a group of concept
for these crappers their cells and mptp
lesion non-human primates so I just want
to very briefly describe you the mptp
model that I've explained earlier and
that you give this neurotoxin mptp and
what we have here is a comparison
between Parkinson's disease and mptp
this is a review from Collier labs and
as well as Jeff record over at rush and
what we see is a both mptp model and
Parkinson's we have this characteristic
master dopaminergic neurons in the
substantia [ __ ] itself as well as the
loss of straddle dopaminergic
transmission very similar to Parkinson's
disease and just important just as
importantly we also get the clinical
manifestation the symptoms of behavioral
symptoms like akinesia tremor rigidity
postural instability so this really is
what we call sort of a clinical
phenotype of at least four motor
symptoms in parkinson's disease and so
when we take these cells that we
transplant them into to mptp lesion
monkeys this is one month
post-transplantation you can see the
graphs are highly innervated there
they're sending axons into the host
brinkema can see an A and B again these
are just being sear these these inverted
images so you can really pull out the
fibers and you can see and see the cells
are still somewhat bipolar so they're
kind of immature we've seen that
previously with dr. snood ourselves as
well and what we've also found as I
showed you at three months that those
cells mature and highly innervate the
brain so what happens at three months so
this is tyrosine hydroxylase game for
these cells and you can see an E and F
that not only are these
I was maintaining their th positive
expression but they also have that very
nice large characteristic angular soma
as well as a highly innovating the host
prank man you can see an F in the
inverted image on the top right panel
there that very characteristic
morphology of these of these
differentiated neurons in the high
authorization air so again we know the
cells survive and grab the attention
even mature and they really are
expressing the right proteins were
actually the process of characterizing
these graphs right now I don't have time
to put the data in but David's just
recently David Martinez just recently
showed you data where D they are
maintaining the Fox say to your
expression and expressing things like V
Matt to and group to which are
indicative of the a9 some type of neuron
which is particularly susceptible
degenerate to degeneration of
Parkinson's disease so now my last slide
I just want to wrap up here I wanted to
sort of show you the global view of
course all we're really trying to do
again is we're trying to recapitulate
normal development and we're trying to
make that cell in the human fetal
metribuzin Cephalon now by no means is
this strategy then sort of abandoned
there's actually a group right now it's
has a clinical trial c'mon called trans
euro and their whole a goal for this
trial is not to try and drinking the
human fetal metribuzin cephalic grass
back but to try and learn how to
actually optimize the strategy and apply
once we have all the technology figured
out there politico stem cells apply
those techniques that they've learned
from human vm into the into the human
situation for pluripotent stem cells
told you about our work with lawrence
tutors lab that's being funded by the
new york stem cell foundation using
human embryonic stem cells and dr.
suitors lab is really spearheaded this
this project and a really tackled full
board they have now into their pre-ind
process with the fda where they are they
have derived their GMP cell lines they
would need a working cell bank and they
really done a bang-up job toys creating
a cell type that could be used
therapeutically and then of course i
told you about
work with CDI that we're working on
towards the same ends again using the
exact same type of protocols as pseudo
raises an IPS cells and the idea here
again we're trying to do an otologist
cell therapy trying to sort of get rid
of someone immunosuppression now I'll
leave you with this which cell type do i
think is the best honestly i don't have
a clue the point is to test them side by
side and figure out which cell type has
the best efficacy now for any of you
cell therapies to be useful clinically
in this goes for any music new
therapeutic we're going to require an
enhanced efficacy over the currently
available treatments and for pv right
now that's oral l-dopa and deep brain
stimulation we show very high efficacy
for around 10 years or so so we already
have very well-established therapies for
PD so the point is is not to make
something that works as well as these
therapies but to make something that
actually works better and creates a more
long-term solution and so I think that
used when we're generating these cell
types oh we're looking at whether or not
we want to use them therapeutically we
really need to keep that in mind that
the point is not to do the same the
point is to keep better and so i'll
leave you with that I just when I want
to thank the people that actually done
most of this work of course I need to
thank my mentor Jeff record over who's
really let me go full at this project
and has supported me since he brought me
to rush over five years we don't know
and then of course these two in the
bottom right of this picture benjamin
hillier there the middle picture and
david Marmion it was a very talented
graduate student with dr. proto over
pictured on the right and really done
the majority this work I just showed you
and then a variety of other people from
our labs and then of course all of our
technical help in the lab we couldn't do
it without them and then last but not
least all of our collaborators I really
owe a debt of gratitude to settle a
dynamics international particularly two
gentlemen Chris McMahon who is the
director for the dopamine project and
really heads up operations CBI on that
end as well as Carter cliff who was the
first person I met from CBI that really
was a champion in this project
throughout and and has been a huge help
towards getting this to look to the
position
right now and then last but not least
Laurentiis tutors lab and sonya Crick's
really for developing this this
game-changing technique and really this
paradigm shift towards floorplate agenda
for played generation in these cells
without them we would be still quite a
ways away from where we are right now
and then all the people that helped me
in graduate school she in redmond evan
cider my my p.i and mentor when I was in
graduate school working with fetal cells
and their last but not least of course
all my funding rush university medical
center CDI and the NIH and with that I
would be happy to take questions from
the audience great thank you just
important thank you for that exciting
presentation it was really great
thought-provoking presentation we have
time for a few questions i just want to
remind everyone that if you have any
questions that you'd like to ask you can
do so now remember to just click the
green question and answer button that's
in the lower left corner of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears and
press end we'll answer as many of the
questions that we can with the time that
we have left so with that let's get
started so thank you all for your
questions the first question comes from
machi ogawa and i apologize if i
pronounced anyone's name them correctly
from applied stem cell linked and I can
only see some of this question but it
says what is the method of
differentiation to dopaminergic neurons
for ipscs is it different from healthy
and pd patients arrived cells so the
method is a slightly modified method
from the Studer method that being said
CEI does licensed doctor stirs protocol
and his is uh their IP so i can tell you
it is is very similar and all of the
tests that we've done using these cells
comparing them to shown that they are
extremely similar by gene expression
protein expression etc
pretty much every parameter we've looked
at has really shown that this that
they're almost identical the next
question was the PD sporadic PD cells
versus the IPS oh so I can't answer that
quite yet because we're still in the
process of driving those cells as most
of you know with any IPS cell line
there's line-to-line variability and not
only how they're derived how they grow
their percentage of cells and actually
you can differentiate from them so
they're always no matter what cell type
you're using to what source you're using
there's always going to be some
fine-tuning some tweaking and that's one
of the questions that were actually
really interested in looking at in CDI
and Chris McMahon's group has really has
really been going full bore into is
figuring out just how much tweaking that
might take coming up with a protocol or
slight modifications of protocols that
would decrease that variability we do
know that that we can create the IPS
cell lines from these cells and we
anticipate there shouldn't be too many
issues with dopaminergic differentiation
itself in the crowd preservation I know
there's other groups around the world
that have done the same they used a
similar approach and have had success so
I don't anticipate any any issues there
so thank you very much for that question
that was a great question let's see here
we have a question from Shuji sebastian
with the cryo step be repeatable in a
real world at a clinic on another
continent so I I think are talking about
the actual cryopreservation of the cells
is it repeatable it's extremely
repeatable this is not one lot of cells
that I'm talking about cellular dynamics
generously cells all the time lots of
lot variability is next to none they
have very very strict release criteria
which is something that's very important
for scientists like us right because we
want to make sure getting the same thing
every time you use the cells so that
release criteria not only is this trick
that's a good thing for them because
they have a repeatable product or it's
great for us because we know our
experiments are not going to change
depending on the lot we get themselves
and i can tell you i have tested
multiple lots of these cells in vivo and
i always see the exact same results and
that was actually one of those questions
you have as a scientist is is you know
this is going to be a one-time thing and
the answer that is not next question I
see incoming is chicago from irvine
scientific have you tested compared DMSO
containing versus DMSO free conditions
post all your functional parameters so
the answer to the simple answer to that
is no we have not tested non DMSO
containing conditions and the reason for
that is that i'm quite happy with the
results we're getting with the DMSO
containing cells there are other cell
products for other diseases using other
cell types on the market for other
companies that are in the clinic that
our crowd preserved I having DMSO in
them the real situation that you need to
worry about here is whether or not
there's residual DMSO in the preparation
when you transplant and that is
something that we can very easily test
we can measure that and as long as
you're underneath that that sort of
criteria that you said that safe that's
been said me and the FDA has guidelines
on that and there's other people write a
look at that then then the prevailing
thought is as long as you've done all
your safety and safety studies you've
shown that it's safe than that's not a
problem so I you know it would I guess
it would be interesting from an academic
standpoint whether or not whether or not
it works without the DMSO we're very
happy with our results with the DMSO and
we don't think it's going to be a
roadblock to the clinic so I guess for
me it's one of those if it isn't broke
don't fix it just be aware of it make
sure it's safe and since there are very
simple ways to remove the DMSO to a sub
threshold level that we would need for
toxicity that's pretty much been our
approach but that's another great
question thank you so the next question
I'm seen is from Neil Reiner and the
University of British Columbia what is
your best estimate of the timeline for
entering phase 1 clinical trials and
what are the
major hurdles to getting there Wow okay
that is a fantastic question Neil
estimate for timeline for entering phase
one we do a lot of this modeling and
looking to try and figure out you know
what's the minimal amount of time what's
a maximal time I wouldn't put any set
amount of time on that and I know this I
assure the question I would I'll give
you some basic parameters i would say an
ideal situation if everything works
three to five years I think I and I know
CDI we're very very concerned with
safety and doing it right not
necessarily being if first person to do
it but doing it right and being able to
reach a large patient population
remember I mentioned that we'd like to
you like this to be available you know
really throughout the world eventually
so you don't need a specialized center
or a specialized technician so estimate
for a phase one I mean it could be as
quick as one or two years if everything
went perfect and the FDA I was satisfied
with all of our preclinical studies
there's other groups certainly lorenz
tutors group is doing a bang-up job
right now with their es dr cells really
setting the bar i think for all of us in
the pd field there are other people in
the pd field that have sell products i
think that are that would be reasonably
test I don't I don't know as much about
them of course personally there are
there's a group led by jun takahashi in
japan that is probably a closer went to
the clinic than some of the rest of us
and he's using IPS cells as well now as
far as a major hurdles getting there I
actually have a whole slide honest I
took it out last night so I'm sort of
regretting that but that's that's the
biggest that's the great question so
when you design a clinical trial
especially for regenerative medicine
there are some major major roadblocks in
the way and when you look at sort of one
of these these timelines it sort of it's
a cyclical timeline it's not like a line
by line horizontal line two
so one thing I've learned in the last
five or ten years working with stem
cells and thinking clinically is that
you really need to design your clinical
trial before you do your preclinical
texts and so careful design there will
save you a lot of time and in reality a
lot of money so you don't have to repeat
yourself and so what do I mean by that
well for any of these cell therapies
this guy don't care which disease you're
working on this is going to be the same
your product has to be very very very
carefully designed as to be safe it has
to be repeatable the QA QC that the FDA
wants is expensive and rightfully so
that's that's for all of our advantage
so this is one thing I think that I
really learned and I admire from the
studio group is other attention to
detail creating master cell banks so
these have to be GMP compliant you need
a master solving a master cell bank a
working cell bank so when you take these
cells and eubank them that's the cell
type your final product that has all
your QA QC that you have to go back and
do all your pre clinical tests on so you
have to gear efficacy tests in rodent
models the disease you need to determine
tumorigenicity tests probably in a large
animal model if you're going to
immunosuppressant certain cases if you
need immunosuppression you're going to
need to look at the safety profile there
so you know again you you need safety
and then you need safety and then you
need safety and one always hopes that
you're also applications as well but the
last thing any clinician wants and
anyone any of us working on this want to
do is take a disease patient someone
that's sick and make them sick or
possibly give them a tuner that's just
not acceptable so everyone that I know
what's working on this throughout the
world whether that be in Europe on loon
there's a very strong group led by mom
parmar people like honor your plan
people like Steve done at Roger Barker
over in car Tiffany and on UK Tito Tito
covers up all these people in Japanese
group jun takahashi lorenz suitors group
they get together once a year actually
they have a meeting called the g-force
PDG force and basically everybody gets
together and talks about what they're
doing and
really a unique a unique approach where
everyone is competing with each other is
actually working with each other to some
extent so that we we are learning from
each other's mistakes and we're all
learning how to get better at this so
it's really a universal good so that is
sort of a long roundabout answer to your
question I really thank you for that
question is fantastic and it's a
complicated question that I think at the
end of the day which you're going to see
is the people that are doing it right
are very systematically going through
this process and learning from the FDA
what they want and I should probably
point out that it's not immediately
clear the FDA doesn't have a set of
guidelines where you must do you know a
through z and will approve this it's
different for every application so great
question I see another question here
from Susie Sebastian from apologize by
watch this lowbrow University so do you
consider a risk-based approach EMA
supported to take the product to clinic
ah you know I'm gonna take I'm gonna
take the roundabout answer on this so
really my job as far as I'm concerned as
a research scientist is my job is to
test the hypothesis in these animal
models of Parkinson's disease that's
sort of my forte when it comes to going
to the clinic I really uh you know I
know my area of expertise and I know
what areas i'm not an expert in and one
of those areas i'm not an expert in is
you know actually implementing to the
clinic so we have a lot of different
advisers of course people like formally
on the fda and this is going to go for
any group so i really rely on the
support of people and in the farming
industry that have been through this
before people that are other people that
are working on cell based therapeutics
consultants that know how this process
exists and so they can inform me as to
how to design my my basic studies my my
safety and efficacy studies with the
final product and creating that final
product and then you know really handing
it off to them to implement that and and
i think one step that that everyone
needs to keep in mind is that you need
to work hand in hand with your
clinicians understand who your patient
population is who are you targeting what
are the symptoms you're targeting you
know you need to have a good working
relationship with your neurologist and
with your neurosurgeons and that's one
thing and really the reason that I'm
here at rush is because we have such an
outstanding movement disorders clinic
that knows how to implement clinical
files so you know really the answer your
question is I I leave those questions
and and sort of those approaches to the
experts in that realm and that's our
main and I let them inform me and talk
to talk to those experts who would
actually be able to bridge that gap
whether it be in the pharmaceutical
industry biotech regulatory or in the
clinical realm so again a very nice
question so I'm looking at the QA and
I'm not seeing anything really on the
board here so i think i'd like to thank
everyone that attended this conference
it was a great honor thank you to
cellular dynamics and the lab roots for
hosting and again we're really excited
about about this work here that we're
doing it rushed in collaboration with
CDI and of course all of our
collaborators throughout the world
really really pushing forward to try and
help with patients and at the end of the
day I think that's the key here that's
the goal is to is to understand that
we're doing this for the patients so I
guess my I like to decide we conclude
with making those patients especially
our donors that are getting those cells
from right now so we can hopefully try
and create a better therapy for them so
thank you very much for your time and I
think we're wrapping up with that hi
once again I'd like to just take the
minute to thank Justin for his great
presentation and for today and hope that
everyone enjoyed it for anybody that had
additional questions that were not
answered please feel free to contact us
at cellular dynamics com and we would be
able to help answer your questions or
get you in touch with Dustin to be able
to further expand on some of your
questions one last note I wanted to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available on demand through a buoy
through leverage for six months from
today's date you will receive an email
here shortly letting you know when this
webcast will be available and feel free
to share that email with your colleagues
who weren't able to join us today thank
you for joining us and we hope to
interact with you again soon